[Music]
welome back the G7 including the UK and
us is calling for humanitarian pauses in
Gaza many other countries in the Middle
East are demanding a full ceasefire
Israel has ruled out of ceasefire while
Hamas holds around 240 hostages who are
kidnapped during the deadly Terror
attacks on October the 7th it says
there's already tactical pauses in his
daily assaults on the Gaza Strip well
more than 10 and a half thousand people
report now been killed in Gaza including
over 4,000 children according to the
Hamas run Health Ministry on Sunday the
pope made an urgent plea to stop the
conflict saying I pray to you to stop in
the name of God cease the fire so with
so much Bloodshed is it time for Ace
fire join me now to discuss this
America's Rabbi and bestselling author
Rabbi shmy bayak and welcome back to
Young Turks creat and Democratic
presidential Challenger Jen yugar well
welcome to both of you um Jen let me
start with you
many people are calling for a ceasefire
Queen Ria of Jordan Angeline Jolie uh
Arab leaders and so on uh I presume you
would agree with
that yeah absolutely uh I think that
they've murdered enough Palestinian
civilians uh and even Netanyahu in an
interview with ABC news said now that
we're on the ground we're finally
pressuring Hamas on hostages oh so the
7,000 bombs you dropped were totally
useless and Collective punishment and
your attempt to murder civilians on
purpose as some sort of sick Vengeance
so please stop the murders ceasefire
right now Rabbi SMY your
response uh Chen is polling in the
Democratic presidential primaries at 0%
nothing he has a greater likelihood of
being elected the new king of France and
no don't interrupt me please and the
reason is that the American people are
decent they understand that
anti-Semitism which he has voiced on
your show repeatedly calling Jews
genocide dares and this is the eve of
Christal the 85th Anniversary of the
start of the Holocaust he would deny the
Jewish people the only dignity left to
us that we were victims of genocide and
he would say that we are the Nazis we
are the Gaper for simply wanting to
defend ourselves against the brutality
and the savagery of Hamas Chang Chang
Chang Chang shank you'll have your turn
just show some decency if you're not
going to show it to my people show it to
me and show it to the viewers of the
show stop but who is surprised that a
man who is surprised that a man who
whose name the name of whose podcast is
Young Turks who perpetrated The Armenian
Genocide The Young Turks is like calling
your podcast the young Nazis the young
gestapo they killed one and a half to
two million Armenians between 1915 and
1918 The Armenian Community has begged
shank to change the name of his show for
the first half of his life he was a
complete Arman Chang now now now now he
is a holocaust denier because he is
saying that the Jews are engaged in a
genocide of the palestin which nation
How can there be 1.8 million Muslim Arab
citizens me I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to
J you said you said some very strong
things about Jen you can now respond
Jen yeah this you should never have the
sky and air everything he said is a lie
I don't deny the Holocaust that's
insanity and in terms of our Manan
genocide uh there is a powerful analogy
there why was it a genocide and yes it
was a genocide why because they moved
and displaced so many people and killed
civilians on the way what is Israel
doing moving and displacing millions of
people and killing innocent civilians it
is the exact definition of a genocide so
I don't I I think the Jewish people are
an amazing people and their their
culture is beautiful and I don't
tolerate any anti-semitism but I think
that the occupation is decaying the
moral core of Israel how long are you
going to oppress these people and I know
this guy all he wants to do is an ad
homonym attack he's a liar he's and you
could tell exactly what kind of indecent
human being he is but the main reason
he's doing it is to avoid the topic when
are you going to stop murdering
Palestinians and cheerleading it if
you're talking about genocide you're the
one right now doing the genocide respond
may I
respond resp go ahead you know I've
spent I've spent my life debating people
whenever someone whenever someone starts
using personal names and screaming like
a lunatic they're losing the debate let
me Remain the made palan the Palestinian
the Palestinians the the Palestinians
were offered to state in 1936 in the
appeal commission they rejected it they
were offered to state in 1947 the UN
partition plan they rejected it they
were offered to state in 1967 after
Israel conquered Judean Samar and the
West Bank they rejected it they were
offered to state in 2000 yaser arat a
Barack they rejected it they were
offered to state with aod Omar 2008 they
rejected it they have the Israel
unilaterally withdrew from Gaza in 2005
and they did not create a state in fact
where were you chank when you say that
you care about Palestinian children when
Hamas stole the highest rate of per
capita International foreign aid larger
than the Marshal plan from Palestinian
children did not build schools for them
did not build hospitals took all the
money to buy bombs and build a network
of tunnels which is larger than the than
the New York Subway system where were
you then why did you only come up now in
fact when Bashar al-assad killed
600,000 children Arab children when he
gassed them with mustard gas my
organization took out full page New York
Times ads to protect them from sarin gas
where are you then you don't care about
Arab children you are a Jew hater
defined as someone who only wants to lie
and say that the Jews are genocide and
don't try to cancel me and say that I
shouldn't be on you're not a producer of
this show because you are ignorant of
the facts and ignorant of the history
does not mean that you can cancel my
voice your
response okay so first of all
you this guy is a full-blown bigot he's
one of the most racist people I have
ever seen does not value Palestinian
lives at all and everything he said
about me is 100% untrue I was vicious in
my criticism of Bashar al- Assad I've
criticized Hamas over and over again and
I think what they did in the attack
against Israel was reprehensible but for
God's sake how long are you going to
occupy these people for me the idea of
Israelis and Palestinians or Muslims or
Jews being different is absurd those are
just stupid labels that we put on people
they're all human beings I value the
Israeli life just as much as I value the
Palestinian life we're all human stop
using these nonsense lab ask kill each
other this guy wants to do is more
murder of Palestinians J let me ask when
are you going to let them go Jen let me
ask you a question you mentioned
genocide there what Hamas is actually in
its Charter dedicated to doing is the
purest personification of genocide well
it is they want to see the eradication
of Israel and they proved on October the
7th they will kill as many Jews as they
can possibly get their hands on so that
is pure genocide what Israel is doing in
return I don't think meets the category
of genocide right because they don't
want to get rid of every Palestinian
they don't want to kill every
Palestinian no they want to kill every
Hamas terrorist now there are legitimate
question marks about how they're going
about this and about the civilian
casualties but there is a there is a a
moral distinction between what Hamas is
dedicated to doing and what Israel is
dedicated to doing isn't
there no uh first of all Hamas is a
bunch of idiots they should take that
stuff out of their Charter it all it
does is has hurt the Palestinian cause
there's no call for it it's dumb and
it's immoral but Hamas claims that they
would like to do these things and from
time to time they do these attacks that
are horrible and they should never do
but Israel actually kills Palestinians
actually occupies Palestine actually
denies the Palestinians estate so
there's this absurd talk of like oh if
Hamas was superpowerful they might deny
Israel its existence except Israel does
exist and is and in the Palestinian
state does not exist because Israel is
blocking their state so stop using Pro
and I'm not
saying hold
on and I you and I you and I Jank you
and I you and I are almost the same age
and I'm actually quite worried for how
upset you get on TV you got to protect
your health you're just kind of losing
it now calm down because I'm upset that
you keep advocating the Mur j j j you
have to stop yelling you have to stop
screaming and you need to know the facts
the Palestinians were offered a state
seven times and they rejected it seven
times Bill Clinton told yasar arat in
2000 you have made me a failure as
president because Israel was giving you
97% of Judea and Samaria and the old
city of Jerusalem and AUD Barack even
offered the Temple mount the Hol ass
sight in Judaism and the Palestinians
rejected it you simply don't know the
history read a book in fact read a
Wikipedia article before you get on TV
number two
you know you made a very good point
before Pierce that Winston Churchill is
the greatest British Statesman and hero
of the 20th century let's remember when
churcher was faced with a genocidal
threat of the Nazis you know what he did
which is what would never consider doing
he laid waste to 70% of Dresden Essen
cologne Berlin he dis he eviscerated
Germany and turned it into a parking lot
murdering about 6 million German
civilians Israel has never even
considered doing a thousandth of that
and FDR acquiesced to it and he's
considered our greatest president of the
20th century and then Harry Truman
dropped two atomic bombs on Nagasaki
Hiroshima so I and Israel has nuclear
weapons has never considered doing that
Israel opened
UPG so I so I have one simple question
Jen I want to ask you question Winston
Churchill a war criminal on this show
today will you call us Churchill a war
criminal all right J that question okay
so Rabbi schi if you're actually a rabbi
um what the standards of history have
changed so the Mongols went into Baghdad
and killed every man woman and child
killed 800,000 people the largest city
in the world now we don't live by those
standards anymore and right now if a a
modern British prime minister or
American president uh advocated for
dropping a nuclear bomb in Japan or
killing 70% of the people that live in
dresen you're damn right I'd call him a
war criminal it's a different situation
today than it was in the past and so
what you're saying is hey we only
murdered 10,000 civilians unwantedly and
recklessly and we only did a partial
genocide so we're not as guilty not I
I'm not buying it at
all I want to ask you a question hang on
Rabbi I want to ask you a question which
is this which is the unique scenario in
Gaza is that nearly half of the civilian
population are children they have
nothing to do with this they're not
politicians they're not in Hamas they're
not terrorists they're not milit they're
kids and they are in their thousands
being killed here and I ask you really
is there is there any limit you as a
rabbi of the number of children who need
to be killed to get rid of Hamas here or
is there no
limit of course there's a limit we mourn
the death of every Arab Muslim
Palestinian child as if a Jewish child
died they are absolutely equal before
God that's why Israel withdrew
completely an utterly in 2005 something
that Jen will not even acknowledge there
isn't one Israeli soldier there wasn't
until this new Invasion because of the
attack on deot because I went to those
places Pierce I was there two weeks ago
I saw the blood caked on the walls
congealed to three or 4 inches I saw the
knives that were used to murder entire
families we saw the place where t not
Jewish Thai Farm Workers who were
growing pumpkins were beheaded we saw
the body of of Shaunie Luke and I spoke
to her mother Ricarda who was taken
naked these are religious men in Kamas
taken naked in her underwear and her bra
her dead body these necrofilia Savages
we saw all that how many how many
Palestinian children need to die God
forbid not one all Kamas needs to do is
let the civilian population go south
stop using them as human Shields Hamas
wants these Palestinian children to die
every Palestinian child to Hamas is a
bulletproof but you said for no other
reason than to humiliate Israel let them
go south and be safe but Hamas wants
them it's hamas's fault it's hamas's
fault it's hamas's fault RAB you did say
there is a limit what is that
limit uh Pierce it's hard to put a
number on how many people Kamas is
prepared to allow to die in order to
destroy the state of Israel remember
hamas's motto is from the sea from the
from the from sea to Sea Israel will be
uh Palestine will be free it's the
annihilation of every Jew Iran calls for
it openly a second Holocaust this is the
eve of Christal I don't want to put a
number on how many Palestinian children
we I want to cease fire right now Kamas
must surrender unconditionally just like
FDR and just like Churchill demanded of
the Nazis unconditional surrender
release the hostages we get a ceasefire
right now Chen let me ask you to call
for a ceasefire by having Hamas who you
think actually cares about the palestini
population announc their surrender call
for their surrender right now they
launched this attack unprovoked against
Israel they slaughtered 1400 people they
are holding little babies whose diapers
need to be changed as hostages call for
them to surrender
unconditionally can we okay so look all
this is nonsense uh first of all Israel
did not withdraw they controlled the
borders of Gaza 100% And as you can tell
now they cut off the water and power
anytime they want uh the Jewish people
have been oppressed throughout history
my heart goes out to the Jewish people
for all the pain and the suffering that
they have endured through all of these
years but now Israel unfortunately is
not the oppressed it is the oppressor
look at them dropping 7,000 bombs on
grandmothers and children there's an
American nurse that explained on CNN
yesterday about how she sees uh little
kids with Burns all across their bodies
so Hamas is terrible yes I can call for
their surrender that's easy I don't like
Hamas I think Hamas is Muslim
fundamentalist but it's an impossible
standard and you know they're not going
to meet that standard and because you
want to keep killing those civilians to
show them how Mighty you are and what a
great oppressor you are I'm sick of it
and it's not only ruining the
Palestinians
their it ising it is cusing of isra
liable blood Lial this is a blood Li
against the Jewish people you may as
well just say that we drink the blood
Christian children and ouring you are
guilty of a blood Lial on the eve of
Crystal you should be ashamed
of I'm call a blood change the name of
your show away from Young Turks who were
genocide
who I'm going to try and wrestle things
back to the host here and call a
ceasefire for now it's been a
fascinating debate very passionate on
both sides I get that I appreciate you
both agreeing to debate each other I
think that's important in this uh
situation and thank you for coming on
the show thank
you appreciate it uh this this guy's
ruining the there's tremendous
anti-Semitism in the world by crying
wolf he's actually
hurting from people like okay you're
bigot stop killing Palestinians you
bigot okay we're going to leave it there
thank you very
much